when you were in prison you were a boxer
weren't you well my uncle started me
boxing when I was about 8 years old he
was fighting Golden Gloves and and I was
I was his uh punching B I was trying
sparting
partner punching so I either had to
learn how to fight or get my brains beat
so I I I got really really good so when
I would get into prison immediately they
would set me up with a fight oh let's
and prison you were uh lightweight and
Welterweight Champion unbelievable and
you said professional boxers would come
to the prison
you and did you hate those guys you you
actually the the the worst thing in the
world about Mexicans is they don't
understand
uh uh they don't understand a uh
exhibition right you know what I mean so
we're going to have this exhibition bout
with like with like the Army that's
coming in and they come by they got
money on you home no no it's an
exhibition yeah know make a money on you
so so I either have to tell this guy hey
go for it or or surprise them one of the
two did you ever sit in prison and go
[__] I'm a [__] Champion if my life
had gone a little differently you
probably could have been a heavyweight
champion of the world or how let me tell
you something my life ambition was to be
welterweight champion of San Quinn right
so you know it's like I think one of the
things that prison taught me now you
know it's like uh I would rather shoot
for the moon and Miss than aim for The
Gutter and make it did the guards and
stuff give you mutual respect because
you were like this Champion yeah if if
you're well and then again if the guards
know you're
protecting somebody right even if it's
for pay if you're protecting your then
they kind of give you a little pass you
have a lot of so you get out of prison
and you even try to start you you
started little business with a sort of
semi-legal boxing matches where right
you would fight no I used to fight I
used to I came out and I would try to
get a a professional license but because
of the violence I have on my record they
put me on two years probation isn't it
amazing violent offenders can't get
boxing licenses I mean you know like
that's the best place for you go fight
somebody beat somebody
up